hola que tal buenos días gracias por la
invitación a 7 años de la
de la del suceso de ayotzinapa de la del
levantamiento de 43 estudiantes en
iguala es el gobierno de méxico tiene
avances concretos pero muy lentos para
mí desde mi punto de vista el el avance
más concreto que tiene es el hallazgo de
los restos de dos jóvenes más de joseba
ni guerrero del de las dos y de cristian
rodríguez este en un en un lugar que se
llama la barranca de la carnicería que
justamente estamos viendo ahí en alguna
imagen esto esto se suma también al al
que ya se había hecho de alexander mora
sin embargo los
los avances concretos para judicializar
las situaciones para encontrar la
respuesta final que no sea la que nos es
no nos interesa a todos los mexicanos
que es saber efectivamente dónde están
los los 43 levantados esa no tiene
respuestas y hay muchas razones
a las fuerzas prácticas todavía en
méxico por ejemplo el ejército
todavía tiene gran influencia
en este país en las decisiones que se
toman por un lado por otro hay hay
otras otras líneas de investigación que
nos están siguiendo
el tema de los infiltrados en la propia
escuela la injerencia de el gobierno del
narco del del propio ejército de las
fuerzas de seguridad en la misma escuela
son fuerzas que el que sean es que no se
han estudiado de manera adecuada y que
de alguna forma se sigan soslayando en
las investigaciones miguelangel por los
general miguel ángel porque han tardado
tanto las órdenes de detención contra
los presuntos responsables
bueno los presuntos responsables entre
ellos tomás era una ilusión que escapa
israel
pues por cosas diplomáticas y por cosas
de papeleo no con israel méxico tiene un
convenio de colaboración que es muy
complejo muy complejo y que impide de
alguna manera este aceleramiento de las
de los procesos en otros en otros este
responsables que es que los mismos
padres de familia señalan por ejemplo el
propio ex ex ex presidente de méxico
enrique peña nieto el ex director de la
procuraduría es murillo karam
éste a ellos no se les ha investigado
definitivamente no se ha investigado y
ese es un reclamo que tienen tanto
colectivos como los propios de los
propios afectados en ese en ese caso
miguelangel si bien los hechos
ocurrieron durante la administración de
enrique peña nieto del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador prometió aclarar
los hechos sin embargo las
investigaciones aún no entregan
respuestas claras cómo afecta esto al
actual gobierno
pues este caso es digamos que es la joya
de la corona de la administración de
andrés manuel lópez obrador fue la
primera la primera promesa de campaña
que lanzó en su
electoral mientras de la creación de la
comisión para la búsqueda de los
estudiantes de ayotzinapa la primera
acción que se toma dentro de su gobierno
entonces por supuesto que afecta afecta
y mucho en la percepción que se tiene de
la de la del gobierno de lópez obrador